incomes in the past years should now pay
their fair share of cash it raises at
most a fraction of what we were told and
may raise not
enough yeah the top rate of tax will be
45 Pence this will simplify the tax
system and make Britain more competitive
it'll reward Enterprise and work
money and the whole country not a plan
for growth a plan to reward the already
wealthy a return to the trickle-down of
the past
the Prime Minister and her Chancellor
say that talented productive wealth
creators should be allowed to keep more
of their money it'll encourage them to
use their talent to enrich everybody
tax cuts shouldn't just be a form of
poor relief
her opponents argue that you won't get
greater Prosperity from greater
inequality and that in the middle of a
cost of living crisis it's just obscene
to give tax breaks to those who really
don't need them
our choice can tax cuts for the rich be
justified as making us all wealthier and
even if they did are they really the
path to a better Britain
in the next 30 minutes we go in search
of common ground
[Music]
with me tonight two of the finest Minds
from what has unfairly been dubbed the
Dismal scientists science Economist
Andrew lillico executive director at
Europe economics and Economist Francis
Coppola who previously in her career
spent 17 years working in the banking
sector I think we can agree on a few
things first that any government would
want to suppress energy costs in this
situation
second that any government would try to
do something about Britain's low
productivity and miserable growth rate
and I think we can probably most people
are currently in agreement about the
decision to cut taxes by one percent
though there is some issue about whether
this was the moment to do it and I want
to come to that a bit later but I'd like
to start by talking about that abolition
of the top tax rate and ask you Andrew
lillico was this right instead of for
example
spending the two billions by raising the
tax threshold which would benefit people
on Modest or middle or low incomes so
what's happened with higher taxes is
that you we some years ago switched from
the much more elegant system which was
introduced by Nigel Lawson of just
having two tax rates at 25p and 40p to
having a rather more complex system
there was a 10p band and then they
introduced this higher rate band and
then they introduced strange tapers in
the middle and the thing got much more
complicated one of the consequences of
complex tax systems is that they create
economic distortions that harm your
long-term growth rate so you can do
subtle manipulations in the short term
and
um uh George Osborne was quite keen on
having this higher rate tax remain even
though he wasn't didn't think it raised
a lot of money because he wanted to give
a signal that we were all in this
together if you remember that Mantra
from the time of austerity but it isn't
an economic efficient way of doing these
things what the government has been
doing is they've Frozen the 40p band The
the thresholder which you go into that
and now they're eliminating the top rate
band so in fact the the implication of
that because that 40p freezing raises a
lot more money than the removal of the
40p band does it's a bit like a transfer
of money from people on a hundred
thousand pounds a year to people on uh
200 000 pounds a year so amongst very
rich people we're we're taking a bit
more money off very rich people and
giving it to very very rich people and
we're doing that because that simplifies
the way the tax system works and
encourages long-term growth and that's
very important for trust to do at this
point because she wants to put down a
marker that she's willing to do
unpopular things in order to Aid
long-term growth
Francis Coppola what's your view about
this was it a good thing to do or not
if you wanted to simplify the tax system
there are very much more important
things you could do than that like
eliminating some of the high marginal
tax rates that are faced by people on
say between incomes of 100 to 125 000
pounds so and maybe increasing the work
allowances for people on Universal
Credit both of those are things that the
chancellor has now trailed but it's
interesting that he didn't do those
upfront but what he did was the 45p
abolition up front and thereby annoyed a
lot of people
there's a bit of a perverse incentive
here isn't there and saying well we're
going to take some money from
one rich group of people and give it to
a slightly Rich group of people
um and that way we're somehow going to
create long-term economic growth I am
not seeing the connection between moving
funds from one group of rich people to
another group of rich people in order to
generate long-term economic growth
growth I would also point out actually
that the higher rate attacks the 40p
rate actually starts to bite at a much
lower income level than that so
um if you so you're actually potentially
leaving taxes unchanged for a much
larger group of people in order to
reduce taxes are very small just over 50
000.
just on on your point Andrew would it
maybe not have been let's just stay with
the question of the distribution between
frankly
uh pretty rich people people who are in
the hundred thousand two hundred
thousand right
um would it have been more sensible to
for example uh change the system whereby
people who own over a hundred thousand
lose their personal tax allowance and
there's a sort of Cliff where they fall
off because actually what they seem to
have done is to created sort of created
um a situation where everybody hates the
very rich but the medium Rich the
hundred thousand people are still not
getting their personal tax allowance and
they're going to loathe the very rich
even more well absolutely they should
simplify that and they will in due
course as well I think and that that's
one of the furthest tax simplification
math yeah but it's good that they got
out of the way the silliest and most
straightforward to remove of the
measures right at the beginning to
Signal a willingness to do unpopular
things in order to um have growth go
faster there's a whole sway of unpopular
things that trust is going to have to do
if she wants the growth rate to go up in
the way that she intends she's she's
going to have to do planning reform
extra onshore wind generation they
already removed the moratorium on that
in the mini budget so he's gonna have to
do fracking she's probably gonna have to
build in the green belt or in Tory
shires there's so lots of planning type
reforms they'll be um changes to
probably changes in the benefits system
uh they'll probably be unpopular
reductions in spending all kinds of
stuff which is going to be unpopular
these are necessary measures if we're to
grow over the longer term and she just
needs to achieve she I think by doing
this was signaling a willingness to
engage in unpopular measures and which
you can get her MPS on side for doing
that at the start she has more chance of
getting them on site for things later
Francis am I sensing my first piece of
Common Ground here that you would both
agree simplification good thing yes
absolutely do we need to simplify our
tax system I would like to see genuine
reforms to our tax system to eliminate
the kind of anomalies we have in it and
generally smooth things out across the
board I would like to see that this
didn't move us in that direction because
actually 45p rates is just another band
it's not silly it's perfectly okay to
have three bands of tax what is
ridiculous is having situations where
particular groups of people have very
high marginal lack tax rates because
you've got ridiculous anomalies in your
system and those are the kind of
performance you could explain for for
the viewers who don't exist in these
rarified
um uh circumstances what a marginal uh
tax rate actually is
it's the tax rates you occur on the
extra bit of income that you you take on
if you get let's say if you increase
your your pay
um it's the extra bit of tax that you
pay on that right so you might move from
earning uh 49 000 pounds to 51 000
pounds and suddenly Wham exactly exactly
exactly okay
um let's just think about then what the
principle of such simplification might
be I mean let's start from the basic
premise of what the government's trying
to do say which is a point you've raised
Francis does it actually make people
work harder
more and more creatively if you take the
tax burden of them are there any
examples that you can think of Andrew in
the world where it that has demonstrably
been true well there's a general
principle there's been quite a number of
um studies across the oecd that lower
tax rates are associated with slightly
faster longer term growth so the rule of
thumb is that for each one percent extra
of GDP
um you lose about point one two percent
of annual GDP growth so if your GDP
growth was one percent then if you had
one percent lower tax over the long term
then you might be going at 1.12 instead
that's why that's a correlation it's not
a causation we don't know that that's
that there's a causation there do we
well it's a pretty there's pretty strong
grounds in theory to think that that
should be so as well it also isn't
Universal so that only really kicks in
once you go above something like 25 of
GDP because there's a whole load of
spending that you that you do at the
beginning that's very growth and hearts
and you know you're not gonna have a
very fast growing economy if you have no
police force or no legal authorities or
various things like that and of course
you probably won't grow very fast if you
have no welfare system because a lot of
there'll be a lot of poor people that
are creating all kinds of problems for
you so the the uh these are it's not
that you don't want to have any spending
an initial bunch of spending will make
your economies grow faster but once you
go into the kind of range which is
normal for oecd countries you have a
range in which there's a trade-off so a
little bit extra
um spending and tax is associated with
lots of things which are nice like
helping the poor and the uh the old and
the sick and educating kids and having
Opera and sports and all kinds of other
things that you fund with government
spending but it costs you a little bit
of growth it doesn't come for free so
that trade-off is something which of
course politics in mainstream developed
economies is about we argue as to where
exactly we want to sit in terms of that
that trade-off but I don't think that
there should be any real doubt that in
general there's higher spending and
higher taxes are associated with a
little bit slower growth well that's in
a way the reverse to what I've asked
about which is uh that the highest
public spending might actually slow
growth but the question that's really
being asked today is whether uh lower
taxes will result in higher growth which
is the case that's being made by and uh
I mean I'm just genuinely wondering
people talk for example about Singapore
whether there are real examples that can
be brought forward and demonstrably show
that this theory that if you remove
taxes on people and indeed on
corporations actually you get higher
growth so in my view that you want to
distinguish between three kinds of
things so one is that if you just reduce
taxes
um across the board say and you don't at
the same time reduce spending all you're
really doing is building up some extra
sit you're putting off the taxes till
tomorrow so you shouldn't expect there
to be any faster long-term growth as a
consequence unless option two the way in
which you reduce the taxes changes the
structure of taxes so that you have a
tax simplification on Improvement in the
efficiency of taxes which had the margin
tax simplification isn't something which
gives you enormous amounts of extra GDP
those are other kinds of measures
they're going to give you about more of
that but at the margin it can make a a
small difference a third kind of a thing
is if you have a reduction in taxes
which is temporary during say a
recession and quite a lot of the um
trust tax measures actually should be
understood so the 45p one is probably a
structural change but a lot of her other
measures which were introduced in many
budget are the cancellation of tax Rises
when we're facing a recession and that
would be very conventional short-term
macroeconomic management policy do do by
the Francis that actually the the
corollary of higher spending leading to
lower growth which I think things
generally accepted also means that if
you do it the other way around you'll
get more growth
um no and I think there's a lot a lot
here to unpick really the first is that
um if I make may work backwards through
your three things if we talk about
temporary tax cuts in a recession we
aren't actually in a recession at the
moment we actually have
full employment at the moment I know our
participation rate has gone down that's
the number of people who actually want
jobs
um has gone down for various reasons one
of which is the very long waiting lists
in the NHS which is actually forcing
people to drop out of the NHS that was a
new financial times today
um
so um when you start to cut taxes you
are giving a demand stimulus into the
economy you are giving people more money
to spend and when you have an economy
that is that full employment is close to
full capacity all you're going to do is
generate inflation you're not going to
generate growth because the economy
can't grow it's like on the ground that
people want more stuff but you haven't
got enough
so the cost of every bit of stuff I
might actually pick up a supply side
reform in trust's package which I think
mitigates that to some extent and that's
her commitment to liberalizing
immigration but that's going to be a
very very hard sell even to her own
cabinet let alone to the population as a
whole I want to come back to that but
the Francis
um one of the examples that's been used
uh widely I think by people who do
broadly support what the chancellor has
done is the Reagan
policy
why wouldn't it work for us
well that to to be clear President
Reagan in the 1980s a lot of
deregulation and actually reduction tax
reductions and indeed the American
economy expanded
two things the first is um there's just
a kind of another of Andrew's points
which is the level matters so when
you're dealing with a kind of top tax
rates that we were seeing in the 1970s
we were talking about you know top tax
rates of 80 90 sometimes over 100 and
um we arguably did have to get those
downs and that was one of the things
that Reagan was doing was cutting the
top rates of tax down to something more
more workable something that didn't
drive people the way that wasn't a
disincentive to even grow businesses and
and those sorts of levels I think a lot
of people would agree that that's
actually worth doing it it would be
growth friendly and helpful when you're
down at much lower levels of tax when
you're about middling when you're about
at the 40 45 P level it's not so clear
that the effect is that great
um so it's questionable whether a cut
from 45p to 40p in the top rate of tax
which is what we're actually talking
about isn't it because that's what
abolishing the 45p band does is actually
going to be that much of an incentive to
the very rich
to come and live and work and grow
businesses in the UK and my second point
is we're not the us we are a small Open
Country
um we are a price taker not a price
setup we don't issue the world's Premier
Reserve currency we haven't done so for
a long time and that does make a
difference and particularly a lot of
essential Goods like oil and so forth
are priced in dollars Andrew this is an
important point isn't it because the the
Reagan example is kind of widely quoted
as an example that broadly speaking
different uh different economy different
country and so on but broadly speaking
supports the idea that if you liberate
people give them more of their money
back they'll do more and they'll do
better
um
how do you respond to to what Francis
has just said the problem with that okay
so there's a few things about the Reagan
thing that I would emphasize one is that
I I think that the key thing that they
that the um Reagan strategy is built on
is the idea that you
um the uh presidency and their allies
have more control direct control over
taxes than they have overspending so in
the American constitutional Arrangements
what they did was they kept the taxes
first and then that was a way of putting
pressure on their political opponents to
agree subsequently to spending cuts
and say to Congress you now have to cut
that spending yeah exactly so it was
that kind of constitutional Arrangement
and one of the things that's going on is
a signal to the world that you're going
to get the spending down and I think
that this point about signaling is quite
important in some of the stuff that
truss is doing here in the UK as well
her strategy isn't the same as Reagan's
but it does have that element that she's
trying to give a story about what's
going to happen over the longer term in
the economy for some years in the UK
economy even at the conservative
administrations we've had almost every
problem that turned up the answer was
spend a whole heap more money and the
tax rates have been going up and up all
the time so we're now looking at the
highest level of taxes for about 40
years the highest the taxes were
scheduled to rise to their highest since
1948 their the whole inflation thing may
not mean that but under if we stuck with
the way that we were going before then
probably we would have gone back and
raised the taxes further so that we got
to the highest level since the 1940s
that we needed to move away from that
path and it's not very straightforward
to do because there are quite powerful
reasons why we ended up down that path
but I think that one of the key things
she's trying to achieve is to signal
from the start that she intends to go
along a different path we're not going
along this ratchet where all the time
you just spend more then you accept
we're locked into that so the taxes have
to go up another problem comes on and
you spend even more again that's not the
way to go it may be a sort of uh oh
great generalization but
um I think the case that would be made
from Downing Street and a lot of the
supporters is that
you can pick holes in the way that's
presented some aspects of the timing and
so on but we are a country which has
suffered from low productivity low
growth literally for decades and all of
the tinkering all of this that and the
other has done nothing and we needed to
do something big bold and radical and uh
the naysayers are basically the kind of
people you that have got us into this
place by basically moaning about every
possible change that could have broken
us out of that cycle
my answer to that would be that we have
not understood the causes of the low
productivity I actually looked at this
yesterday I looked at the public sector
net investment position over the last
40 odd years
um do you know that public sector net
investment was cut to Zero by Thatcher
is actually negative at one stage
and that during his first five years in
office Blair didn't do much about it
then he increased it during his second
term in office
but then it was cut back again after the
financial crisis
public sector investment has been far
below its previous levels its 1970s
levels for really 40 years so my
argument would be under the price we pay
for that is actually that things that
actually investment that actually could
increase growth that could increase
productivity I've mentioned one thing
already which is doing something about
waiting lists in the NHS to actually
enable people to get healthier quickly
because one of the reasons we've got a
lot of people not in work is because
they're sick yeah absolutely absolutely
when Mr Lawson uh cut taxes uh at the
end of the 1980s he was very specific he
said first of all what we've done
reduced inflation
secondly what we've done is introduced
what they would call supply side reforms
a bit more investment
taken some structural problem barriers
away and then and only then actually I
think seven or eight years maybe nine
years actually after that Mrs Thatcher
came to government only then did they
start slashing taxes is there a problem
here about
the the speak the sequencing the speed
with which Mr quatang is trying to do
this
well I mean at some level there is that
I that would be the ideal way of doing
things on the other hand it's worth
bearing in mind that the level of taxes
which we which we have now are much
higher than than um than he had so and
another thing he cut from an 83 no no I
remember the young man one day hoping
that I'd earned enough money to pay 83
tax no I'm not talking about the I'm not
talking about the income tax rates I'm
talking about the aggregate tax okay so
the aggregate tax take
um was similar in about in 1980 81 to
the to the tax tape that we have um
today but it had fallen a lot they also
got much better control of public
spending through from the mid-1980s
onwards so you're absolutely right that
there was a and ideally they would have
more time but the reality is that they
don't feel like they have the time to do
these things with that luxury they need
to just go for it all guns blazing
because they only and have a couple of
years till the next general election and
the economy at the levels of debt and so
on that we have doesn't have the time
time to wait to change Francis would you
you're not opposed to the idea of
reducing taxes at top level are you or
are you no actually I'm not in in an
economy that can sustain that I just
don't think this should be the priority
um if I might just talk a little bit
through this idea that we had faster
growth in the years before where we are
now
um we've had a couple of occasions now
where faster growth has been created by
cutting taxes and deregulating and on
each occasion it ended up with a credit
boom and a disastrous crash both times
that has been the story of the last 40
years is that we kind of turned Along on
a not very
um not very fast growing basis and then
somebody says so what we need to do to
get things moving is to cut taxes and
deregulate and yet that creates a credit
Boom the financial sector takes off we
the housing market blows up and then the
whole thing crashes is that what we're
trying to do again on that cheery note
let me just move you both to from the
sort of pure economics to if you like
morale morality question
um
one of the founding myths of this
country is what you might call the Robin
Hood philosophy we take from the rich
give to the poor everybody feels
comfortable about that what is being
said here or done here it is said is the
reverse of the Robin Hood
done this weekend consistent with what
is felt to be British morality Andrew
well I I don't accept that
characterization of things particularly
I would say it was more a matter of
taking from the rich and giving to the
very rich but in terms of the
distributional impacts the the and it's
also very rich in giving to the rich or
the other way about sorry taking that
maybe taking from the rich yeah taking
them rich and giving to the very very
rich but another thing the main thing
which they announced in the mini budget
the main um is significant measure in
terms of its impact on households is the
energy price package and that's going to
benefit people on Lower incomes
enormously more relative to their income
than any of these tax effects have for
the higher up so what we're actually
doing with that with that if you if you
did care about these kinds of equality
issues and I don't and I don't think one
should you don't care about equality not
not at all I have no interest in
equality
I think it's an incorrect policy
objective uh um so I don't think it's
either morally or
um or economically sound as a policy
objective so I have no interest in that
but even if you did care in that about
that the main thing which they're doing
is in fact helping the airport much more
than the rich Francis morality of it
right well if I might come in just as an
economist to start with a distribution
does matter
um and that actually
um when you concentrate everything at
the top end like that
um the the amount of bang you get for
your buck as it were is much much less
than if you actually do things on the
more broadly based basis with the
intention of bringing um increasing the
prosperity of of a much larger number of
people the idea that by cutting tax
rates on the on the very rich you
somehow create an environment where
goodness trickles down to lower levels
it has been massively debunked there is
zero evidence that it ever happens
except on an extremely short-term basis
um it I don't really think we should be
doing this again okay Andrew just really
before before we finish just coming back
to one doesn't have to be a supporter of
the trickle-down theory but there's been
quite a lot of work as I understand it
done by economists in recent years that
suggests I think as France has been
saying that uh
economies which have less inequality
built into them are a bit more
productive do you not accept that at all
well first of all I think that I mean
trickle down was a term that was used as
an insult term against Hoover back in
the 1930s there aren't really it's
there's nobody who thinks
um in in terms of current economic
policy that the aim of giving money or
of
um cutting taxes or of giving benefits
to those in the middle energy package or
whatever is the impacts which they have
on the poor that whole thought that the
only reason you could have for helping
richer people is the way in which you
help poor people is the kind of equality
agenda gone mad the reason for helping
the Richer people and for helping the
people in the middle is to help the
Richer people and the people in the
middle because they're people too if you
make if you make their lives better then
that's good that that's part of the
government's job is to help make
everybody's lives better not only poor
people's lives better well it's um
wonderful to know that I have completely
failed on our first show back back on
the air with common ground except that
actually one of the things that both of
you do agree about is simplification and
I think that there's quite a lot that
could be said and done on that front
secondly actually neither of you is
completely opposed to the other side on
the question of what you do about giving
more money back to those who make and
contribute make a lot of money and
contribute a lot of tax both of you sort
of think the issue is is now the right
time and what would be the right way
right point in economic cycle uh to do
this now that you disagree about and as
a consequence both of you are still at
complete odds over what mistrust and Mr
quateng have done so my failure I've got
to confess though I I'm still on the
point of view that there may be
something to be said for the benefit of
a more equal Society being more
productive but that's maybe for another
conversation thank you both for being
part of this conversation stay with us
we'll have all of today's news coming up
after the break
[Music]